Girls, keep everything tidy.
There’s cold roast for dinner.
Have fun in Boston, mom.
Listen to me, while I’m gone,
clean constantly.
♪♪
Now the house is perfect and
Betty has made me the most
beautiful dress.
I even washed my hair last
week.
♪♪
It is so crazy. Sue is an
influencer.
Really? I can’t even believe I
know her.
-Mmm.
It tastes like booze.
Yes I soaked it in brandy for a
month.
Oh, we’re free, we’re free.
-Oh my God that was awful.
That was awful.
O'Theo Le garbage jata.
Let’s go hit that cattle show!
(Cheering)
Hit the cattle show.
Cows, chickens.
Mmm.
Get up, Emily.
No.
-Don’t make me goooo. ugh.
Today is gonna be good for you.
But I hate my life, I truly want
to die.
And that’s exactly why we need a
spa day.
Whoa!
What?
There’s a lot going on over
there.
What do you mean?
Where?
It’s like your brain is on fire.
That tracks.
What’s this?
Why is the boy over here in his
slippers?
Our son is throwing a tea party
for his friends and I’m going to
help.
Well can’t he take care of
himself?
No.
I must present you with a bill.
♪♪
You’re a crook.
I’m actually America’s first
ophthalmologist.
This is outrageous!
I’m useless as a father.
Dad don’t say that.
You raised three kids and all of
us are turning out just fine.
Oh, (Raspberry) cmon.